no I look I think there's some truth and
I think the church doesn't really talk
about like the the baggage like they
don't really like talk about the baggage
that comes with this stuff and like
warning men about predatory women
because there are predatory women I
totally agree with you look I totally
agree with that there are predatory
women I think it's a big statement to
say the church doesn't warn people about
this because I know plenty Catholics
plenty of Catholics who would say like
yeah stay a virgin try to marry a virgin
I also know others who say it's
important to be yeah yeah okay well I
know nice well and I also know people
who would say it's good to be equally
yoked right like yeah if you don't think
you could handle that if you're a virgin
and this person uh has slept with a lot
of people that that is something you
consider in your discernment it's not to
say like you're evil because you don't
want to marry someone who's not a virgin